today we're going to talk about the
relationship between fasting during
Ramadan and its immune effects Ramadan
lasts between 29 and 30 days and you're
required not to drink or eat anything
just before sunrise - just after sunset
this is a dry fast and what I mean by a
dry fast is you're not drinking any
water now before we get into the
benefits I do want to point out this one
very very important point if you look at
some of the studies done on Ramadan
you're gonna see some mixed reviews and
I think the reason for that because what
you eat before and after you fast is
going to make or break your success if
you are eating a lot of junk food or
refined carbohydrates that is going to
greatly inhibit these amazing effects
that you could achieve if you added heat
to friendly foods low carb during the
meals I mean think about it ketones in
general are antimicrobial when you do
fasting you actually decrease with cold
cytokines there are different types of
cytokines and cytokines are chemical
messages that communicate between your
immune cells there are certain cytokines
that cause inflammation and those are
the ones that we're talking about so
it'll decrease the trigger to
inflammation also it will stimulate
something called macrophages a
macrophage is a large cell that eats
bacteria and microbes and viruses this
is like a professional what's called a
phagocyte which not just like a garbage
disposal but it is a deadly killer any
one of the first lines of defense for
any type of invasion for microbes the
more you can stimulate macrophages the
better the immune system all right next
thing is it will increase the microbiome
what is the microbiome that describes
your friendly microbes in your body that
help you a great majority of your mewn
system and I'm talking like 70 percent
is located in your large intestine and
I'm talking about a microbiome which I
did a video on and I'll
that link down below gives you
incredible immune support and without it
your risk for infection go straight up
and vertical when you do fasting which
is kind of weird because you're actually
kind of starving them they live longer
there's certain type of genetic things
that get triggered that support your
immune system
next thing is resistance to stress when
you fast you increase your capacity to
fight off stress as well as DNA damage
to also when you fast you decrease
oxidative stress you're gonna have less
free radicals you're also going to get
an increase in production of your
antioxidant networks which also can help
as well and lastly fasting will increase
the Tov G which is your body's ability
to recycle old damaged parts as well as
microbes there's a very specific type of
Vltava G called xenophanes which targets
pathogens one huge benefit of fasting is
basically the elimination of these
microbes that can stay dormant in your
body for many many years
Ramadan has huge powerful effects on the
immune system but I think it could be a
lot better if you also add Kino if
you're new to my channel I put a link
down below of exactly what you should be
eating to enhance your benefits if you
want more information about fasting
check out this intro video right here